welcome to the Nano Springs webinar
titled unraveling the complexities of
amino ecology with 3d biology technology
before we get started with our two
speakers I'll go through some
housekeeping updates the first one is if
you cannot see the slide please put in a
request into the technical live chat if
you have questions through the webinar
feel free to ask use the ask a question
feature to submit a question and we'll
make sure to answer that through the
discussions that we have if there's
questions we have not gotten to we'll
make sure to give you a full answer
after the webinar with that set let me
now introduce you to our first speaker
who's dr. Alessandra Fasano she spent
the last two decades focusing on
clinical and you know oncology research
she has an experience and passion for
aiming oncology research and she's
joining nano strings to really explore
what optical barcodes can do in terms of
answering some of the most interesting
questions in clinical immunology so with
that said I'm gonna turn it over to
Alessandra Solano start presenting on
what's new and exciting and amino
ecology in Kenya in good money everyone
around the world and thank you very much
for joining this webinar today my goal
in the next 20 minutes are to briefly
review our current understanding of the
role of the immune system in cancer and
how we translate this understanding in
clinical effective treatments a listen
first except attention although at the
same time we've learned that we need
novel biomarkers to guide both from a
mechanistic point of view as well as a
patient selection point of view in
effective development and clinical
implementation of novel you know
therapeutic approaches so let's start
since is a big agenda and the immune
system has greater potential for a
specific destruction of tumor cells we
not explicit your normal tissue in for
long term memory that can prevent cancer
currents and the the for from these
becomes the promise of immunotherapy
that means to all really provide
long-term cure the last 30 years of
immune oncology research have provided a
very solid evidence that the tumor are
recognized by the new system and their
development can be stopped or control
through a process that we call him you
know civilians so you know surveillance
is really a theory that the immune
system is able to recognize the sole
tumor cells that are constantly arising
during the life of the individual and we
call this elimination phase however
engaged when the immune system is not
able to completely eliminate the
two-month forest when the tumor become
less Ingenix or the individual become
less incompetent a state of equilibrium
development whereby the tumor does not
progress and so it's not completely
eliminated there is no clinical disease
evidence in this case like there is not
in the elimination phase this stage
could be lifelong and thus mimicking the
elimination phase or can be disturbed by
changes in the tumor or in the earth
which allow the tumor to escape so when
the cancer cells resist or boyd or
actively suppress an immune response
they really need to tumor escape to date
the most studies of the immune system
interaction doing perform in this
particular phase so the state phase of
the union of surveillance
so the tumour immune system interaction
are shaped by different factors and we
can systematically just for easy of
thought divide them or characterize them
in three buckets they asked the cancer
in the environmental factor they all
work together and converge through
shapes
the interaction between the concerned
immune system so I will go through all
these different buckets one by one so
let's start with the off weld immune
response in cancer has been described
very elegantly by our mailman and deli
chain as a cycle the council immunity
cycle and these really a series of
carefully regulated events that can be
self-propagating each step of each step
of this cycle required the coordination
of many factors both monetary and
inhibitory in nature and this is the
reason why an assessment of this process
need to be learned as a group cannot be
done singly
let's go through the different steps so
the first bag new antigens they are
created normally by the process of
oncogenesis are relieved by the tumor
cells and that's sorry there is a delay
in the image pushing again
okay and anyway the first step there is
the new antigen released by the tumour
cells and we are captured by the
dendritic cells in order for processing
in order for these steps we need to
provide an anti-cancer t-cell response
it must be come along with other fingers
done by transformatory cycle cytokine or
faster desire needs by dying cells or by
the gaseous microbiota what we call for
storage at ceremonies in the next step
that you feel alrighty now we have the
dendritic cell is presenting the natural
antigen on the MHC class 1 and refers to
monocles to the T cells unless this
process results in the timing and
activation of the effector cells against
specific cancer antigen importantly the
nature of the new response is the
terminal D stage and really critical for
the final outcome of the immune response
is the ratio the fine aeration between
the effectors in T regulatory finally
the activated T cells traffic to the
improve the vessel and they go in the
tumor band where they specifically
recognized combined the cancer cells to
an interaction between the T service
sector and the is con yet bound to them
MHC class 1 and then they kill the
target cell during the killing of the
target cells there is a release of other
tumor antigen and that's an important
process that increase the breast and the
death of the response in the start the
subsequent revolution of the cycle so in
cancer patients this cycle does not
perform optimally the tumor antigen
might not be detected
they dendritic cell all the pieces can
treat the antigen itself and where the T
cell may also not properly on to the
tumor or factors in the microenvironment
can suppress those effectors
so what is important
that there is limiting step any given
patient can be different so the goal of
cancer immunotherapy is really to
initiate or iterate self same cycle of
cancer immunity and I will enabling to
amplify and propagate the cancer immune
response without a machine in English
kind of numerous forms but the most
effective approach will be the one that
involves selectively targeting the rate
limiting step of cells in any given
position and this is where the need of
biomarkers is really stemming from
so let's look now at the factor at the
level of the tumor they can change the
immune to more interaction the genetic
and cellular alteration the define
cancer provides also the immune system
with the antigens that generate in
effect immune response so essentially
the antigens that allowed the tumor to
be recognized as non-self and in this
regard association between the tumor
mutational load and response to
checkpoint inhibitor is being clinically
demonstrated really does suggest means
that a pre-existing adapting new
response in a set of tumor is actually
present however and very interesting
recently he has been demonstrated that
the tumor from quadratic uncle Jaime
pathway can contribute to the immune
evasion and that is important because we
will explain the preferred of the tumor
in human they do not show a pre-existing
adaptive immune response and therefore
individuals the JSE group is identified
a melanoma is very intrinsic oncogenic
pathway they win basic Athenian pathway
the contribute contributes to the lack
of the cell infiltration in melanoma
similarly Patrick newsgroup to show that
the tumor contains loss which results in
an activation of the pi3 kinase pathway
results also not decrease in T cell
integration and the
humor sighs and finally the group of
viewers I'll provide evidence of a
normal human evasion mechanism that are
mediated by epigenetic events from non
rotational events francese epigenetic
silencing of th one size similar
altogether this new finding unimportant
because they taunt to new candidates for
a mineral potentiation so finally the
role microbiota in the progression of
extra intestinal tumors as only emerged
recently showing the day abundance of
specific commensal bacterial species
announce the anti-cancer activity or
immune checkpoint inhibitors by
modulating systemic inflammation whether
a major question remain how is deciding
our element in humans and I'm sure that
a lot of new study will help us to
understand that so using the gene
expression signature or using actually
Minister chemistry today we can identify
two major to more success in solid
tumors one-third of the tumor are the
one that they gave a t-cell inflame to
more microenvironment signatures in the
yet marker of the cells
infiltration or the gene expression of
particularly functional signatures
associated with the cell activation and
these and the one that reveals a
pre-existing adaptive immune response
that's suggesting that really the
expression of local military factors are
at play here for this time of humor are
the one that we look at the next slide
are probably likely to respond to
checkpoint inhibitor at the act at the
level of the peripheral trials the
second group of tumor are the non t-cell
inflatable they have no T cells
infiltration and so they suggest that is
a lack of
made immune activation orderings a
problem in the official traffic we have
discussed before forcing in the
non-homogeneous up way so essentially
for this tumor they approach from a
therapeutic point of view will be to
break central tolerance or to manipulate
the oncogenic signal pathway so re
pristine eighteen eighty so trafficking
so the very different factors that can
play in the cancer immunity cycle
provides a wide range of potential
toxins
some of which had been successfully
exploited cuticles particularly the
auntie CTS the one antibody against
countries to deal for the ntpd one
people one pathway so what are these
also called checkpoint inhibitors the
immune checkpoint receptor are crucial
molecules that really are designed to
fine-tune the immune response
physiologically the checkpoint signaling
damping's
the t-cell activation to avoid bottom
you missing a effects of information
response the checkpoint blockade
therapeutically used monoclonal antibody
that release the bridge for from these
suppresses cells around them to activate
them to recover
anti human activities really the
Renaissance of cancer immunotherapy
begins with the day aunty city l4
monoclonal antibody in human us in
melanoma City r4 is a transmembrane
protein that is expressed on the surface
of t-cells upon activation and the
binding of this molecule with daleiden
results in a downstream signaling the
culminate in T cell invasion and the
creams of cytokine production and
introduce reaction so they importantly
the checkpoint function of CTS for is
the primary importance in the lymph on
compartments and for most part is
limited really to the activation of
ninety three cells they anticipated for
antibody if Illumina was approved in
March by
the FDA in 2011 for advanced melanoma
and also the response rate was
relatively modest what was particularly
striking was the fact that about 1/5 to
1/4 of the patient at very durable
response really the plateau of responses
was a teen years stable at 10 years this
is the closest thing we have in oncology
to obscure in addition more recently the
antibody is also in approval in the
adjuvant setting the second not
signaling accident that has been you
know news therapeutically if the wonder
consists of the 2 D 1 and D flag and the
PDL 1 and appears tier 2 and the this
pathway is also a negative regulator but
of the immune response in the periphery
the control is controlling the tissue
damaging at the level of the parasite
and so they this explains in part why
the immune adverse events of the
blockage of this pathway are less linear
or the one that disappeared for however
what is important to realize is that
these two pathways represent to these
things normal and and mechanism of
immune regulation and so this is
important because it's the base for the
losing combinations of these currently
they are to fda approved and typically
here one monoclonal antibody and while
they are targeting the same pathway and
there are many other in late stage
development that will become
commercially available so as I say they
are really targeting the same mechanism
action and we are targeting the same
receptor but they have currently
different indication and that is just
reflecting the different clinical
development and you can see the
indication in this life and so I'm not
going to go through that just for sake
of time however importantly if that
despite the recent clinical success of
this checkpoint inhibitor in
a single agent and in combination in
certain humors outside melanoma in the
certain subset of patient like Audrina
means the mass majority of patient with
metastatic solid tumor do not respond to
checkpoint inhibitor and until the
combination of more effective they are
also more toxic in dispensaries so the
development and effective development of
military physic drugs require new
biomarkers however because of the
consequence of the immune responses and
the tumor biology it is unlikely any
single biomarkers will be very
informative theorists to disregard
regards to today the majority of the
work for the anterior one molecule has
been done in evaluating for the level of
the protein using immunise of chemistry
the PDL one whoever gives an issue there
are seven drug in development and target
in this pathway and they currently each
the current practice is independently
for each of these companies really to
develop their own actually immuno
chemistry action and that's going to
create a matrix of diagnostic and drugs
the first results in challenging at the
level of the clinical application in
addition the PBL one as also as marker
as a single analyzed marker is a series
of pitfalls mainly in their cellular
spatial and temporal encouraged inanity
contribute to the poor prediction
accuracy of these biomarker in the
clinics however because of the
complexity of the interaction that I
just described between the tumor and the
Austin immune system isn't even
rightfully they just looking at one
analyte
we will have very important information
in the decide protein the other is to
analyze they can be measuring the tumor
and just include the RNA in the form of
gene expression profiling at the tumor
or at the level of the new system as
well as the DNA
by measuring walk bought the tumor
molecular alteration as wellmaybe
frequency the diversity of this East
Asia region and we are example of that
all examples frequency or non small cell
lung cancers treating with the temporal
determine actual Association as I
mentioned before between tumor board and
in clinical benefits but we have also
examples of that in the gene expression
profiling in particularly examining the
gene expression profiling in the tumor
in the relation of the clinical response
as shown by those Arriba's and asked
here and shown that particularly
signature in particularly in it was the
Unionists signature or a gene expression
signature it was developed by the merck
scientist on the nano stream platform so
that there was and best initial was
allowed for an improved selection
impatient it were likely to respond to
one hit PDL one therapy with centralism
and one important was that these
expression signature was not just few
more specific but when was tested in a
PDL one positive and the next squamous
cell carcinoma show also a positive
predictive value i mean particularly
it's much superior negative predictive
value that's suggesting a potential
broad applicability of these new kind of
biomarkers so also the measurement of
each of these different analyzed is
useful the next generation of biomarkers
we need to measure integrate the
complexity of the earth of the tumor or
the environment and that's required
measurement of different molecular
entity perón a DNA important awfully
using the same samples so that you
maximize the amount and the type of the
information that we get for samples and
also measure in the same units so the
ability of measure any combination of
DNA RNA in protein from the same sample
simultaneously on a single system is
what we define
nano screen 3d biology
we believe it is provide the technology
they provide the level of granularity
that is needed for the next generation
of ie predicting biomarker in you know
college and this level of granularity
the size now achievable Shiva ball on
the nano SIM platform in dr. Joe vision
we'll discuss in detail and the
following presentation so the Reutimann
role in Diesel's one of my last slide is
really to make precision ecology not
just a promise as I started but actually
a reality through the development of an
integrated immune oncology profiles
which measure a integrate information
from relevant of tumor biology
microbiota in the lab in a decision tree
method manner to identify the ultimate
limiting step of cells in the immune
cycle so we can properly match the drug
mekinese of action with the tumor of
biology at the level of the single
patient so I think I'll be stopped here
and I believe you just threw in that the
last slide that is essentially
reiterating what what I actually say it
definitely just light ray like that we
do believe in nano screen offer the
tools to discover these novel biomass
and to develop them into the next
generation of immune oncology diagnostic
and I'm sure that dr. deterrence will
convince you of that
Isana thank you for that fantastic
presentation arm in this basically mean
oncology discoveries are being made
every day so thanks for sharing coming
here some of your background in terms of
how you see the space how some other
therapeutic strategies are as well as
what the future holds for you mean
oncology there's some questions online
for you I will take a couple now before
we go on to Joan's presentations the
first question is around do you believe
it will be possible to distinguish
responder versus non responding patients
prospectively prior to immunotherapy
through biomarker profiling will this be
more difficult in patients who receive
prior treatments
well I definitely think we are already
doing some of this work I think some of
the data that I presented very quickly
but they're essentially suggesting that
our understanding for the interaction
between the tumor and the new system and
also the him with the effect that
environmental factors like microbiota
arrive indeed interaction is increasing
tremendously our understanding of what
can be what could be the different steps
in which you know that are altered in
the ontology
I definitely think we are this knowledge
is ready to be translated practically in
a tentative truth that is inside will
allow to integrate information so then
we can do this in a more accuracy way
with the new screen and expose patients
in successive anything from line
treatment in a much more beige you know
biology base instead of the empirical
basic we have today I think it's going
to be not the future of 20 years it's
going to happen very soon already we are
making big steps forward our founder the
the next question is probably more in
dear dear heart regarding companion
diagnostic what do you think are some of
the best practices for validating and
developing prospective biomarkers into a
companion diagnostics I think that's a
very good question because is that I
just mentioned we know much more about
the biology but he's not only to
understand really what is their biology
that we use again a diagnostic it's
really the discipline and the knowledge
in the superb ility of moving these
science through a very regulated kind of
environment and with eye quality and
standardization of process so that says
these and do that together with the
pharma for the means and the from the
other side with the drugs which they try
something diagnostic so these cannot
happen why
science happen in the epidemic hi so all
these three steps are important there is
science in academia the diagnostic
company as well as the pharma we need
all the sleep and the same tables you
look at the problem from different
aspects but there's a unified problem
otherwise we will end up with a lot of
science the never really impact the
patient Thank You Alessandra for the
remaining questions on the line we'll
make sure to get those answers to you
after the webinar at this time we're
gonna move on to the second part of our
talk and I'd like to take a moment to
introduce our next speaker dr. Joseph
Beecham's was the head of our Rd Joe
spent some time in academia but then a
spent well over the last decade
developing high-end next-gen sequencing
technologies and he recently joined now
sting for several years ago to really
think about how to develop more
capability out of bar coding
technologies optical bar coding
technologies he's the inventor of our 3d
capability and so today we will talk a
little bit about how 3d biology works
and how we plan to use that to
understand biology especially in the
space as immune oncology a great space
today and
on this great talk and the hope you get
a feeling it's a real privilege for me
to be able to work hand in hand with the
CMO like Alessandra cause and that way
sort of my responsibility is the
technology development but it really has
to be guided by the correct type of
medical understanding of the problem so
you know administrating we work very
closely together to really try to
develop technologies that will actually
help and translate some of these
exciting discoveries that we make in
science and actually use them do some
good with them I actually get them to
patients so but I'm going to describe
you today is actually a development of
technologies to try to work hand in hand
with Alessandra so that we can develop
these technologies that actually get
applied in some realistic manner so you
see on this slide and you have to bear
with me the people on the phone cause
I'm used to pointing at things and who
knows where the pointer is going to show
up but I'll give it a try but I think
the key thing here is that
administrating running R&D is great
because I only have to solve one problem
it's how do we get more and more
biological information at a smaller and
smaller amounts of clinical samples when
our vial under biological understandings
exploding so we have to be able to
follow that explosion in understanding
with the right kind of biomarkers that
can represent that information so this
is just a couple of slides on the
introduction on how managing technology
works key aspects about ministering
business technology developed by Lisa at
the Institute of systems biology and I'm
sitting here in Seattle day I can look
at the window and see the is because
that's that's why we're in Seattle
and these are the key developments
related to development of single
molecule counting optical barcodes and
the key thing I think for you to
remember is that we multiplex up to 800
different analytes and it's all digital
detection so you can't get more digital
than counting a single molecule and
that's what these single molecule
optical barcodes allow you to do and
I'll describe now the chemistry so I
just to give you an idea on how the
chemistry works and how you can interact
with us as a company you know you can
sit in your desk and what
see here two reagents one reagent does
the optical barcode the other region is
the Callas call to capture probe these
are the things we make in our
manufacturing site in Seattle and if you
can order up custom or we have
predefined panels for them but just
imagine you're sitting it you're in your
office and you say you know I want to
measure the mRNA associated with say a
key important immune regulator let's say
you are interested in in pd-1 so if
you're interested in PT wonnum they try
to get this pointer thing works and is
what will happen here let's see if a
partner shows up what you see there is
an optical barcode and the optical
barcode the city your desk and say okay
I'm going to dream up 50 base pairs
actually not dream it up you would
actually say I'm interested in measuring
pd-1 if I'm interested in measuring pd-1
what we actually do is you send us a
gene name and we will synthesize an
optical barcode with a 50 base pair
overhang and that would be a
hybridization target for say the mRNA
for pd-1 and then say you're interested
not just in pd-1 but you want to measure
ctla4 40 ppl to PDL one all together
then what we do is we synthesize one of
the time hybridization targets for each
one of those species and what we do is
we just move the little colors around on
that optical barcode so you're PD you're
ctla-4 could start blue yellow and then
when we make the 50 B stereo
hybridization target for say ops 40 all
we do is put the yellow ball first the
blue ball seconds and then that
represents the second target - you can
measure we make all those and our GMP
facility here in Seattle put them all
together in a tube and generate
multiplexer assays that you can run
basically what you need to supply on
your side of the equation and basically
the raw nucleic acid that comes out of
your sample you can see that they're
highlighted in red you know key aspects
of our technology is we don't do
amplification we're not doing a whole
bunch of cDNA conversions we actually
all of our technologies hybridization
driven so we can measure the nucleic
acids directly as they come out of the
sample tissue of interest and that means
communication you automated
instrumentation just simply purify this
tripartite complex and does a single
molecule counting now when we work with
protein technology and this is a
recently developed technology what we
did is actually set it up so that we
label primary antibodies you can see
that on the left hand of the slide we
label primary antibodies with a small
single-stranded 16 mer DNA and
everything else it works what happens
the same so you actually interact with
your sample just as if you're doing a
flow cytometry experiment or if less
than him you know histah chemistry
experiment except now when you get at
the end you know go into a microscope or
a flow cytometer you can actually add
your hybridization barcodes they
hybridize with the nucleic acid on the
protein and then you digitally count
them similar is the way you count
nucleic acid
now you know when I claimed with mr.
actually about four years ago I'm sort
of as guilty as everybody else you know
I made genomic instrumentation or I made
proteomics instrumentation and all these
different things you know the fact is
that that's not the way mother nature
works it actually pays no attention to
these genomic boundaries or proteomic
boundaries it has a whole series of key
molecular internalized that it makes and
the fact is that it utilizes all these
different analyte classes together so
when I came over from life tech you know
one of the key things that I was
interested in doing was let's take these
optical barcode technology and
distribute it so that in a single
simultaneous reaction I want to be able
to count DNA molecules I want to be able
to count the mRNA molecules and I want
to be able to count the protein
molecules all simultaneously so I can
actually understand the biology of the
system in totality and that's the key
effect and fundamental nature of our of
our technology this light gives you an
idea on how we accomplish this it's the
little sprit profiler it's the benchtop
encounter system on the right there you
can see up on the on the left side of
the slide you know we start out with
cells or tissue of interest and what you
can see is we start out and we need
about 5 to 15 anagrams to do are all of
our DNA profiling so this is if you're
looking at copy number single nucleotide
variants in those things of that nature
same cell pellet will be used actually
we'll use about 100 nanograms of the
total RNA and they're actually monitor
things like mRNA expression micro RNA so
on and so forth and then we'll use about
a half a microgram to a one microgram of
the protein to actually do the protein
profiling all of those together can be
optically bar-coded
counted out at the single molecule level
in a completely digital manner and that
sort of forms the heart of what we call
this 3d biology approach what I'm
showing you here is actually some of the
very first raw data that we collected on
3d biology see
I get this cursor to work this time who
knows whether it'll actually go where
I'm pointing
but what we're actually looking at here
is we along the x-axis would be 5,000
cells where the cell input and then on
the y-axis is 5,000 cells that
represents a biological replicate so
this is the way we sort of debug all
these assays so a perfect biological
replica should have a slope equal 1.0
and when you can see when we do these
kinds of experiments combining in this
particular case we're doing a
simultaneous analysis of 770 mRNAs those
are all little green data points we're
doing 15 proteins those with the orange
boxes and I got five genes fusion events
in there the purple triangles one
positive and four negatives and again I
got them all analyzed 5,000 cells in a
tube and you're getting a slope of
biological reproducibility that's nearly
up you can see 0.98 out of opposing a
1.0 so with a single 5000 cell input I'm
sort of get to the next accomplishment
as if I've done a targeted RNA seek
experiment at about 250 to 500 X so if I
ran maps back on 15 different proteins
and then actually set it up for about
five different cytogenetics fish
microscopes probing gene fusion but here
we're just doing our single cell input
on a single encounter system all digital
output all the data can be plotted on
the same graph so we call this when you
actually put your digital data together
like this and optically bar called code
all these individual components and
allows you to combine that all together
we call that the reading biology the
ability to measure any combination of
DNA and RNA protein on a single system
and I'll show you a number of important
applications of this technology going
forward the technology basically solves
a couple of major problems one of them I
denote I call it the lost in translation
problem this is the problem I think I
spent about 80 percent of my time and as
a professor at banding actually tried to
do translational
research and customer the hipster thing
is like one of my protein in house it
doesn't match my RNA and it's like which
measurement do I believe and which ones
right it can't tell you how much time I
wasted spending uh solving that problem
similarly I get my DNA doesn't match my
routine analysis so what do I do with
that when you collect data with 3d
biology you don't have to worry about
that anymore all the digital data comes
out together
so that there is a disparity and what
you measure due to the biology not
because I don't have the right
normalization factor form I'm a
spectator or something of some sort like
that connection solves additional
problem it's a different one and this is
really key and if you're really
developing translational assays when you
got to perform a bunch of different
tests what you find out is that you know
by time I gave one that peak slice to
the mass spec people and maybe five of
them to the mass spec and ten of them to
the sign of genetics people I don't have
enough tumor to go around and actually
perform all these analysis so I have to
decide who gets what and what a terrible
decision has to make with the 3d biology
you're never splitting up your sample
you get all that information at the same
time so you don't have to make those
terrible decisions on how much sample
goes to which which measurement
technique to answer what type of problem
now we developed it I guess we like this
I'm sitting here looking at Nero he's a
great next to me we like this RNA
protein technology on September 11th of
this last year actually we're giving a
talk action at a high-rise in Manhattan
on September 11th it's a great time to
be in high-rise Amman I don't but anyway
the what you see here is that we
developed this technology and you know
it's no good if it only works in my lab
I mean it has to actually be totally
reproducible it has to work in your
hands so one of the key things that
mirrors set up was actually going out to
the early access customers many of these
customers are genomics tile customers
they hadn't measured the protein in like
20 years or something we put this
technology in their hands and you can
see how it works in their hands so you
can see the intro user reproducibility
and that's just incredible look at that
the mRNA protein replicates actually
work when you're inside say one user
doing it you do something harder let's
actually make two different users on the
lab do the same thing and what you see
is you get an exceptional
reproducibility on technology so it's
not a technology it just works in my lab
it will look work in your lab and you'll
be generating vesting class reproducible
data from the simultaneous multiplex
analyses
I'm going to walk you through some case
studies now why do you that would have
been showing you sort of like the
analytical power of the technology now
what I'm going to show you is an
analytical power doesn't mean anything
unless they can actually answer you know
interesting biological questions so one
of the first ones we look at you know we
just don't go jumping immediately into a
complex amino oncology problem to solve
when we're developing this so when I was
a profit dandy and the lab right next to
me is a guy that discovered some
molecules called growth factors and I
did a bunch of work with this guy Stan
Cohen he got the Nobel Prize for that
but we did a bunch of work together on
understanding how a biological system
responds to growth factors so when we're
debugging this 3d biology approach what
a great model system to use put a growth
factor on a cell and watch the entire
cascade of mRNA protein changes that
happen after the epidermal growth factor
binds to a cell so what you see there on
your right are data as it comes directly
out of some of the foundational panels
we developed for studying cancer in this
case here it's the cancer pathways panel
there to your right so when you actually
do experiments with our in this case
here it's a 770 Plex the miner is all
the key cancer driver pathways we don't
just give your all numbers output we
give you those number output and then we
superimpose those digital mRNA results
on to something that's interpretable at
a pathway level in this case here at
kegg map so you can see every little red
box means that when that cell is exposed
to epidermal growth factor everything in
a red box is the digital mRNA that goes
up everything it's a green box of
digital mrna that goes down and you'd be
looking at basically 13 take max
pictures like this the monitor the
response so that's sort of what
registering was always best-in-class of
doing but now we can actually with 3d
biology we can actually examine the
system at a whole nother level of detail
so what if here is all the great mRNA
pathway dependent results that's what
we've been giving groups you know
translational researchers and biomarker
discovers for a number of years now but
now what we're doing is superimposing on
that mRNA results you can see it's all
at little squares at all
circle there on your left you see that's
the epidermal growth factor receptor now
at the same time I'm getting all that
mRNA result you follow that little arrow
over to total protein and possible
protein signals you can actually look at
the change in phosphorylation state of
epidermal growth factor receptor in real
time as it responds to the EGF signaling
so you can see also EGF go up 15 minutes
it spikes up then you actually see it
turns around and actually start cycling
back down that's exactly the result me
and Stan found at Vandy takes about one
day for the fall so receptor the turn
that signal off come back to the surface
and then be ready to be charged again so
it's very nice to be able to see that
the 3d biology to represent that result
I said okay that's still a little bit
too easy let's go inside yourself make
sure we can actually probe the finer
Dalek protein changes at the same time
so we did that so that's the second
little ball you see there follow that
logic true this games here we're looking
at false low Earth plus mark you can see
also spikes up at 15-minute shows this
one day cycle time but there also see
the little green data points I have here
this is the digital mRNA count
associated with one of the phosphatases
that are going to take the phosphate off
fossil Earth thing called dust P 10 you
can see I can make that direct graphs of
mRNA and super superimposed it directly
on a protein and I'm not doing some
amazing normalization here this is the
way that digital counts come out I can
plot those together in time I sort call
these 3d movies of these types of
transitions
okay so I'm going to so I've talked a
lot about how mRNA and protein works
together and then another development
that's brand new that were coming out
with that I want to describe here is
that we've enhanced and invented a new
batch of optical barcodes that allow you
to be able to probe single nucleotide
variants absolutes a DNA level and the
mRNA level we feel like this is very
important because these single
nucleotide variants are often linked to
particular driver mutations or if you
want to link back to Alessandra thought
this is sort of the private life of the
tumor cells as they try to grow and
escape the immune systems often times
length of these key single nucleotide
variants so we invented barcodes that
actually have single nucleotide
resolution and keeping with our
philosophy we measure it at the DNA
level which you see on the left but we
also measure it at the mRNA level that
you see on the right so every single
nucleotide variant in DNA doesn't always
show up in mRNA so you want to be able
to measure them in both places in
actuality they don't always end up in
the protein either so no 3d biology
allows you to track them from one place
to the next to the next and we can do
this tracking all the way down to very
small amounts of tissue that wall
tissues or cells that have the single
nucleotide variant in it but suspect
down to about 5% and you can see we
worked in sort of beste class five
nanograms at 50 milligrams total and
plus we can resolve these types of
transitions so again what I'm doing here
is a sort of an intermediate step we're
going to sort of move from sort of a
model growth factor system to something
closer to immuno oncology and then I'm
going to lead you into actually what
some of this data looks like when it's
embedded inside clinical trial work so
I'm going to go pretty quickly here
gives you an idea if melanoma is one of
the key driver pathways was this b-raf
v600e single nucleotide variant so we're
going to do a simple model system study
we're going to test for the presence of
a single nucleotide variant we're going
to measure how the cancer mRNA to
respond we're going to measure how key
IO proteins respond all
plus and minus a beer as inhibitor so
you actually see a drug response
superimposed on this entire profile so
I'm summarizing a bunch of data here
just look towards the middle and the
right columns so the middle column of
data that is related to the case where
we genotype and that happens will be the
wild-type phenotypes if you will and
what you see there you go right
underneath the fear a permutation graphs
and then you look at that what happened
to all the mRNAs and there's cancer
pathways when you apply that be rampant
editor but when you're a while type
nothing happens so you see that little
volcano plot basically no messages
change greater than at a 50% confidence
level in that entire cell system we also
looked at some of the key I approach
things on the cell surface same thing
you don't see anything that happens when
you're a wild-type genotype you really
don't respond to a beer inhibitor but
then you look over on the right side you
see if this case here is the genotype is
a double mutant for being 600 is what we
measured but then you look at that gene
expression plus or minus FB referent
hitter and you can see from that volcano
plot it it literally is what it's called
it explodes what changes and what you
see is that you look at that response so
that genotypes to that beer ass
inhibitor you can see all the explosion
of the intracellular mRNAs and you can
map these like every family that's
responded that's all was built into sort
of the encounter software associated
with measuring these panels so you can
actually see the explosion then monitor
every individual cancer driver pathways
changing now on the bottom there what
you see is that what we're measuring
here is actually an off target effect so
these are changes on cell surface immune
along ecology proteins hlad RA and CD 73
you can see that they actually are
responded to a targeted inhibitor as
well worried about that we first found
it but then when we actually went in the
literature
flow cytometry and actually found one of
these in CD 73 and then qpcr and
actually seen the HLA DRA responding to
them or estimate treatment so we
basically discovered and was able to
recapitulate
in a single experiment one tech in about
three days recapitulated you know
probably about 500 papers worth of
experiments here okay I'm going to sort
of leave the land of sort of a sort of
model systems behind before I do that I
just emphasize there's nothing more
frustrating when you're in the lab
collecting data you know and then be
limited by evidence off-site data over
some violence or madison's that you may
or may not be able to schedule and get
time with the Ambler and they may not
understand your system and so on and so
forth so we actually spend a lot of time
in Rd actually writing open source or
statistical software that'll allow you
to be able to city your bench you know
you have a technician masters postdoc
person they can actually accomplish
about 90% of their data analysis sitting
at their own death you can do that the
day after you collect your data and we
thought that was very important we spent
a lot of time writing advanced software
so that would empower you as the
experimenter actually be able to analyze
and interpret your own data so now I'm
going to take you into some of the
foundational panels that we set up to
study cancer and these are the types of
foundational panels that are actually
being put into Exploratorium you know
oncology clinical trials we basically
set up a whole series of 770 Plex assays
that work on very small amounts of
clinical sample material that measure on
the Left all the key cancer driver
pathways the one in the center and we
worked with Kol and I'll describe to you
how we did that special Sonor and
seventy Plex for immune profiling and we
also have another Center in 70 clicks
linked to monitoring cancer progression
and metastasis he's all worked together
so as a foundational group we can
actually monitor the entire hallmarks of
cancer series interacting with the
experts in the field of immunology for a
number of years so I've got three years
ago we started interacting with a group
called the immuno sport consortium led
by Jerome Galan it in Thurman Paris he
did some of the really foundational work
by Flo sorting individual tells pills to
NRT cigs figured out all the RNA in
there
generating RNA signatures all that
information became part of our
foundational immuno oncology panel
that's available out to you what you see
on the left on this slide is actually
some of the original work that Jerome
has accomplished in each one of those
little heat maps or RNA signatures
unique to 24 different infiltrating
immune cell types all those learning
signatures are built into our immuno
oncology profiling panel I think it's
available and then on the right you see
what some of the data looks like in this
case here it's actual losses group at
GSK and what you're seeing there are
ministering digital responses these are
activated cd8 activated teaming for
these are actually human activated seats
and floors how they responded to be
ransom Mac inhibitors and that's a paper
you can reference and take a look at the
raw data stream data this is actually
one of our very first immuno oncology
products and you can see launched in
September 11th 2015 and the high rides
in Manhattan if you will and one of the
key things we did is actually put some
of the most important of the protein
target sees this as you can see on the
left the immuno cycling that Alessandro
very elegantly described the entire
immune cycle and how it progresses we
worked hand-in-hand with Alessandro you
see on the right hand side our digital
optical barcoding assays that we
developed for key protein targets as you
walk around that immunity idol and you
can just go by the numbers here so image
and presentation that area - well we got
cd4 cd4 T and cd4 T L set up for that
and you can walk your way through there
key thing is we got key digital protein
based assays that will work together
with our mRNA assays to allow you to do
some very advanced immune profiling so
now I'm going to walk you into some of
our clinical trial works you know one of
the first groups we interacted with on
this 3d biology essentially the father
of protein biomarkers in cancer a guy
named Gordon Mills Gordon lat Gordon
Mills was lab did the entire rppa
project for TCGA so all that data you
see the proof
is done with Gordon we also work closely
with Jim Allison who he wanted
discovered in ctla4 one of the biggest
myths covers she sort of broke up in
this entire IO area and we're involved
in interacting with them on their entire
immunotherapy and targeted therapy
clinical trial program and we committed
that IO and I won't go through this in
any kind of detail but if you can follow
the last couple of years one thing after
another after another we're doing in
this space and while you can see a nice
quote from Gordon work and he leads
systems biology and says the 3d biology
approaches the perfect way to actually
monitor these types of systems okay so
how does it actually get used and I'm
discovering on an IO discovery manner
this is what we got so typically your
samples come in two flavors you
typically have a date zero for us an
excisional biopsy tumor excisional
biopsy that will be pro profiling with
their IRL profile you also have a
longitudinal study with PBMC fractions
and we monitor the entire both of these
together just gives you an idea with
some of our initial clinical trial work
is actually it was our first one where
we're simultaneously monitoring in this
particular case we're profiling the PBM
speed fractions you can see the heat map
in the lower left hand side turned out
the genetic content in our I Oh profiles
has sufficient information so that it's
self segregated an unsupervised manner
it could distinguish the combination
therapy aren't from them from the mono
therapy treatment arm that very nice
thing there all I have to do is make a
volcano plot you see in the lower right
hand side and a lower right hand slide
discovered seven mark biomarkers key to
the combination therapy response this
was three days of experiments here
tourism
picks the samples up on a Tuesday
morning we had the seven biomarkers on
that Friday morning we met with the P is
under that we're leading that study
showed them the sentence and top
biomarkers now we were blinded for the
mechanisms of action of the combination
therapy and turned out six to the seven
biomarkers there actually were linked
directly to the mechanism of action that
they unblinded
for us after showing that results so we
have a number of examples like that this
is one we showed at city a recent
important society for immunotherapy
in cancer meeting and National Harbor
Maryland we did just about a month ago
or so again another k4 in the middle of
a clinical trial in this case I do in
the editor you can see on the left hand
side we're doing full-blown I see immuno
scored type of monitoring done on the
right you can see the immune profiling
from the Nana string technology and
there was a beautiful one-to-one
correlation
high NIAC was high in our molecular
profiling low and IC was low in our
molecular profiling of course the
molecular profile gives you 770 answers
so all sorts of additional information
you can glean from these immune
profiling signatures I'll show you one
example is not done by up so this tools
being put into in this case here it's a
safe to clinical trial called calm and
I'm just going to highlight what the raw
data looks like you can get a feeling
and just concentrate on the right hand
side that's the raw biomarker discovery
targeted biomarker discovery data coming
out of our immune profiling panel you
can see the tumor the original tumor on
the far left and you see high-resolution
selling numeration with multicolored IAC
then those samples those exact samples
were put into our immune profiling and
the things you see up so you see along X
the x-axis d0 y axis is day a treatment
and you can read the biomarkers directly
off of the excursions above and below
the slope equal one line there and and
discover your biomarker signatures
directly out of the immune profiling
technology 50 there's about 14 posters
presented I just highlight there's just
to remember to tell you that a lot of
activities happening this work just
shows you the company like Merck for
their drug Pio drug called katroo de
develop manner strain signatures may
announce that ASCO that they're
interacting with us for clinical trial
sa development work this is a recent
paper literally came out just about a
week ago showing how our immune
profiling along the way
axis actually maps in detail with
digital pathology for both PDL one and
cd8 a couple key markers of course for
and they're just using our immune
profiling panel to get this information
there's no pathologist looking to a
microscope to get this information in
that particular case this is my last
slide essentially puts the whole thing
together you know we believe like
Alessandra described that you know to be
able to look at the DNA level the mRNA
level and protein level are incredibly
important we understand this area than
you know oncology we're supporting it
and we're developing these tools will
allow you to take and sort of be the
first to invent you know be the first to
invent a 3d signature that's gonna be
impactful in the area than you know
oncology these tools are out there
they're ready for use and you know I
hope you can have some fun and actually
do you know a great help you know this
this immuno oncology technology has such
a powerful ability to help patients and
affect patients lives that we really
need to get this technology out as
quickly as possible so these tools are
designed to do just that and I think
we're in a good place to stop and take a
series of our Q&A there it's all right
there in your oh thanks Jill thanks for
walking us through the 3d technology and
explaining how it works with some of the
key applications oh we have a series of
questions around the platform the
chemistry the sample type questions run
concurrent so we'll try and get to as
many as we can in the time remaining we
will start off with a question on sample
type FFPE continues to be the most
challenging sample type when you think
about extracting DNA RNA protein
information in the 3d Biology context
how well do you think this after they
will work with FFPE samples as you know
near I mean we're committed to clinical
applications you on clinical
applications you have to be able to
measure on ancestry so what you'll see
the current commercially available RNA
protein is actually four cells and
associated cells think you can run on a
flow cytometer on the first half of this
year you'll see this protein technology
migrate right onto
ssp we are routinely doing multiplex sfe
on tissue slices of templates and uh and
if you come up to the upcoming AC art
meeting you'll actually see a show data
36 flex proteins on FFP so so they
committed to the space and you'll see
the protein and the mRNA technology and
single nucleotide variant technology all
math that's at P the first half of this
year so we have a question around the
instrument capability encounter and the
question is patents instrument already
being validated approved for clinical
use
um and the tissue uses a biopsy after
treatment so the first questions around
the use of the instrument in clinical
applications and the second is again
sample compatibility yes we have a whole
line of instrumentation we have a line
of instrumentation and we give them
different names to them associated with
this so you have a instrument called the
Flex instrument the Flex instrument has
actually been an F is a fully cleared
FDA instrument that's what we developed
our in vitro diagnostic posting to ask
the breast cancer assay so and so forth
so are all the 3d chemistry works with
all of our instrumentation our Flex
instrument has been cleared for the FDA
so you can actually develop your assays
move them right to the clinic and then
we have this benchtop instrument that's
called the sprint profiler and that's a
less expensive low $150,000 box that can
sit on your bench top
that's not FDA cleared but it allows you
to have your own version all the
chemistry is identical though so
whatever you find on the old bench top
instrument you can immediately migrate
over to the fda-cleared instrument so I
know we're up on time but let's take one
last question and on the protein
capability there's a question about the
process of probe hybridization
compatible with the preservation of
anybody antigen interaction yes so all
you know what we do and again this
depends and we really follow the
mechanisms associated with the proteins
right here so if you have you have a set
of antibodies they've been cleared or
validated for flow cytometry types of
experimentation we have 3d biology
front-ends that allow you to
accomplish that in the antibody
environment that it's used to working in
an absolutely common tree application
and still give you your mRNA and your
single nucleotide variant information of
that same sample type you happen to be
working with an antibody that's cleared
and validated for a Western Norfolk
immunohistochemistry than this we allow
that sample types to follow that
particular protocol and our mRNA and snv
work will follow that protein lead so we
develop these things so that they're all
compatible but we let the antibody
actually be the one that we sort of if
you want to think about we serve the
master which is the protein antibody and
the mRNAs and snps we adapt that follow
thanks thank you Joe I know we're up on
time I want to thank everyone for
joining this call as I mentioned there's
more questions here than we've answered
so we'll make sure those questions are
answered and look at those answers as to
you all we also want you invite us you
come and join our future webinars will
have in the coming month they'll focus
on some of the new innovations that are
going on spaces amine oncology but also
some of the innovations that are
happening in Joe's lab around 3 D
biology and in the coming ones we'll
start to share some of the capability
that we have on measuring DNA RNA and
protein with that thank you very much
and have a good day so - Joe - Joe
Alessandra for their presentation my
name is Gary Weis and I'm a principal
scientist here in Australia I'm going to
address a few additional questions that
came in online primarily around the 3d
biology platform so first we have a
question here about the C and B assay
the Ministry and BSA how large of a
region can be assays to measure copy
number of unique regions so if I
understand this correctly right so where
we develop a custom platform for the
detection of nucleic acid so if you're
interested in copy number variations you
can design probes to the genomic
sequence and of course we have about in
our current system we have about 800
probes can you
to to assess a particular region or
regions within the genome so it really
depends on what sort of resolution
you're looking like for some of our
panel products we use three to five
probes to cover a given gene if you want
higher resolution than that of course
you can design probes across that that
cover the region more thoroughly so it's
really kind of up to the customer and
how many how many genes and how many
regions they can cover based on the
resolution that you want there is no
limitation to the length of that region
just how many what the resolution is
across that region okay
there's also a question here about how
the 3d Biology signature approach
complements
how the 3d Biology signature approach
compliment and/or work with current flow
and amino acids and in clinical trial
applications so I'm not I'm not sure
exactly what you mean by that question
but essentially you know what we believe
is that you should be able to to measure
all three analytes on this system in a
clinical in a clinical environment of
course is we're not directly the same as
a flow as a flow cytometry or
immunoassay at those approaches but we
are you know we have the ability to
measure proteins on an FFP slide for
instance and you can measure RNA from
FFPE so it should be able to fit into a
clinical trial type of scenario and that
we were you know obviously that would
have to be clinically validated and go
through the proper regulatory channels
and and that has not happened for the 3d
biology product as of today
I have a follow-up question about the
CMB asking about what about custom
probes for the CMV and of course yes we
can do a custom probe so for instance
you could design if you so desired if
the region was large enough all 800
probes to cover a big region of genomic
DNA you know so that would cover almost
let's say you space them every thousand
base pairs or so you could cover you
know almost a mega mega base in region
and if it were larger than that you
would obviously have to spread those out
further so again you know our
bioinformatics can work with you to
design to answer the questions that you
need to answer depending on the
resolution that you desire for the CNB
analysis okay so with that there are no
more questions I'd like to you know
thank you for attending and again thank
the presenters and we look forward to
hearing from you thank you so much